when we go to the movies it is the
actors we depend upon to draw us into
the story to make the characters real
and in turn to make us feel it is the
actors with whom we make a special
connection the five nominees for Best
Actress in a leading role all breathe
life into their characters and made our
movie going experiences memorable the
nominees are Helena Bonham Carter in the
wings of the Dove Julie Christie in
afterglow
judi dench in mrs. Brown Helen Hunt in
as good as it gets
Kate Winslet in Titanic
and the Oscar goes to Helen Hunt is as
good as it gets
Helen Hunt has acted in more than 18
films including twister of our profits
and Peggy Sue got married this is her
first Academy
um the first time I saw mrs. Brown saw
it three times the first time I saw it I
leaned over to my beloved and said she's
gonna win an Academy Award and in my
mind tonight she has and so has Julie
Christie and so has Helena Bonham Carter
and so has Kate Winslet and for that
matter so is Billy Connolly and so has
Ben Affleck and so has Joan Allen and
I'm honored to work in a year when there
were so many magnificent performances um
I'm here for one reason and that's Jim
Brooks one single reason and that's the
only reason really that's the only
reason I think I'm tired of thinking you
I thank God for giving me a little piece
of you um Jack I worship you you know it
Greg I hope you hold in your heart how
beautiful your performance in this movie
was like to thank our producers Bridget
Johnson Christie's you Larry Mark
everyone at Sony the team of experts it
took to make me available for this movie
my acting teachers Lorene Tuttle
wherever you are
Gordon Hunt Larry Moss Gary Austin for
giving me a way to learn about myself
and the world and a way to express
myself I hate to think how I'd be
without that my parents who are sobbing
at this point my friends who were at
home jumping up and down and you the
very very best man I know thank you so
much this is a magnificent honor thank
you
you